[Music]
american actor kelsey grammer most
famous for portraying dr frazier crane
in the long-running series frasier has
lived a life full of ups and downs
we're here to give you a look at some of
the most tragic events from the actor's
life
kelsey grammer was born in the u.s
virgin islands where his father owned a
bar and grill called greer's place
when grammar was around two years old
his parents decided to separate and he
moved with his mom and sister to new
jersey and then florida meanwhile his
father stayed on the islands he married
someone else and fathered more children
grammar was deeply attached to his
grandfather
who raised him with the actor's mom
sadly grammar lost him when he was just
11 years old which of course turned out
to be a huge blow to him since he didn't
have a normal relationship with his
actual father
what he didn't know back then was that
he would have to endure a lot more
tragedy over the next few years
tragedy struck again in 1968 when kelsey
grammer's father frank was killed the
future actor was just 13 at the time and
his father's passing happened not long
after his grandfather's
a taxi driver named arthur b niles set
frank's car on fire and then shot him as
he ran outside
niles was described by the local news as
militantly anti-white
believed to be mentally ill and was kept
in a psychiatric ward for many years
in 1994 he was set free but ended up in
jail in 2003 when he threatened a judge
grammar didn't know about niles being
released until he read about it in a
tabloid
he later became vocal about the rights
of individuals who'd been subjected to
heinous crimes
grammar's father was a rather vocal
magazine publisher and was controversial
on the islands for his outspoken nature
his murder led to a rise in racial
tensions between the island's whites and
black residents at the time
as for grammar losing his grandfather
and dad in such a short period of time
was a lot to take in
grammar and his family went through more
heartbreak when the actor was 20 years
old
in july 1975 grammar sister karen was
kidnapped assaulted and murdered
rammer was the one who had to identify
her body my granddad on my father's side
when i called and told him about karen
he just said this family's cursed
karen's attackers were two men named
freddie glenn and michael corbett they
were found guilty and initially put on
death row a decision that was later
overturned corbett died in prison in
2019
glenn tried to seek parole several times
but grammar has blocked his attempts he
told bbc radio 4
i have learnt to forgive i have even
told the guy i forgive him although i
don't advocate his freedom i don't think
that is reasonable
the punishment shouldn't be worse for
the family than it is for the guy that
killed the person
in an interview with vanity fair grammar
reflected on this horrific experience
he revealed that he told the parole
board in 2009 that he misses karen
immensely
and that as her big brother he felt he
was supposed to protect her when he
couldn't he was gutted
kelsey grammer had to live through more
trauma when he lost two of his
half-brothers stephen and billy in a
scuba diving accident five years after
his sister's passing
when billy didn't come back to the
surface after the dive stephen went
looking for him
sadly he passed away from an embolism
probably due to an ascent gone wrong
billy was never found grammar has
acknowledged in interviews that tragedy
has been an integral part of his life
he told vanity fair every one of us is
going to experience some terrible loss
i just got a big dose for every story
you hear that's tragic
there's another that's equally tragic or
more so i think you come to look at
it as part of life kelsey grammer got
into drinking and drugs in a bid to cope
with the pain he felt from the numerous
tragedies that plagued his early life
his drinking ended up landing him in
prison in 1990 for drunk driving
in regards to this he told parade i've
been through my share of tough times i'm
a very different guy now
grammar's vices weren't limited to
alcohol and drugs
promiscuity extreme experiences and
general recklessness were all a part of
it
he has stated that he considers himself
an addictive personality and that he was
on a self-destructive path he continued
i got in too deep i probably would have
died if i hadn't stopped
luckily for grammar his frazier co-stars
knew he needed help and did everything
they could to support him they even
organized an
intervention for their friend three
years into the series while it was hard
for the rest of the show's cast
because they weren't sure what would
happen the intervention worked he
voluntarily checked into the betty ford
center in 1996 to overcome his addiction
and find a life of sobriety
when it comes to his personal
relationships drama is seemingly
unavoidable for kelsey grammer he's been
married three times and endured plenty
of heartbreak until he found peace with
his fourth wife kate walsh whom he
married in 2011.
are you happy yes
yeah grammar revealed to interviewer
graham bensinger that his third marriage
with actor camille grammer was
exhausting
when he was asked to describe any point
in a past relationship when he knew
things wouldn't work out he said
my previous marriage honestly i don't
really talk about her camille very much
because so much of her life is spent
talking about me
grammar said that after his mother
passed away his ex-wife threw a tantrum
at the funeral and started asking him to
divorce her
he said that the couple had been
involved in the same conversation for
eight long years and he was tired he
continued i realized at that moment that
i was done with her that i was not going
to end up in this relationship for much
longer and somewhere under a year i was
done
on top of that grammar's second wife an
exotic dancer named leanne suhaney was
abusive
she would insult him in public and say
hurtful things to him toward the end of
their marriage she told one of grammar's
friends
that she planned to shoot him and burn
down their house after which the actor
got a restraining order and ended the
marriage
kelsey grammer and his wife kate had
more than one miscarriage before their
kids were born grammar told the eye
newspaper
kate and i had a couple of miscarriages
before we had our first child
that was devastating these things are
hard but when it's good
it's magnificent i survived my previous
relationships just in time to land in a
place where i could be in a relationship
with a terrific person where grammar was
with leanne suhani in 1993
things were rather difficult the couple
were expecting their first child when
things took a turn for the worse rammer
had filed a restraining order against
suhani and sent her a notice demanding
an annulment
zuhani who was three months pregnant at
the time didn't take the news well
and attempted to take her own life
fortunately she was rushed to a hospital
and treated
however the pregnancy was aborted a few
days afterward grammar remarked in a
statement
i'm deeply saddened by the events
leading to the loss of the unborn child
i had dreamed of raising the baby in a
stable and loving environment
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk
8255 in 2008 kelsey grammer went through
a health scare when he suffered a heart
attack his publicist stan rosenfield
said at the time
rammer experienced symptoms saturday
morning after paddle boarding with his
wife camille at their hawaiian home
he added that the actor was rushed to a
hospital where doctors concluded that
he'd had a mild heart attack
in 2012 when the actor looked back at
the incident he said that he was
grateful for the experience
telling oprah it was a good thing in my
life it was the physical manifestation
of whatever lesson was being taught to
me which was you better fix it your life
now kelsey grammer's troubles have been
numerous to say the least and that
includes legal troubles
in 1995 a babysitter accused him of
assault
a charge for which a grand jury declined
to indict grammar the jury ruled that
the young woman's year plus delay in
speaking out about the incident and the
lack of physical evidence made it
difficult to back her claims
after the grand jury's decision grammar
made a statement that he was ready to
move on